hey guys back with carrot Roseanne's
kitchen table and I want to talk a
little bit about Bill Cosby this is the
story that's not going away I've told
this many times how 1983 I was seven
years old sitting my parents then I
watched himself his HBO special it made
me want to become a comedian literally
changed my life this is a true hero of
mine so this whole story is sickening to
me like it actually like makes me feel
nauseous now it's something like 30
women just this week in huffington post
a former entertainment executive
hollywood executive she now says that he
did the same it's the same story with
the drug and then not remembering et
cetera et cetera waking up naked the
whole thing but what i wanted to focus
on here is that it pretty much everyone
thinks he did it but i wanted to focus
on this idea of just the trial by
opinion yeah what's going on here
because most likely none of this is
going to go to trial probably it's all
past the point of statute of limitations
and all that but and and for it's
incredible to me that Cosby actually is
still touring he's getting heckled a lot
now but he's actually still out here by
sticking people are still going yeah
literally another they were protesting
against them to all kinds of stuff
people are going just to yell at him
like it's getting kinda it's like beyond
the pale it's beyond the looking glass
he's also at this point he is elderly
he's he's almost completely blind isn't
he I mean he's not in the best I don't
know what his general health is but he's
definitely not who he used to be no he
definitely is in a sharp is janna me but
right so we could there's all that that
kind of details in the sadness of what's
happening now but this idea that people
are convicted sort of without a trial
yeah this thing's never gonna go to
trial unless someone finds out that he
did it like a year like recent right so
assuming that it doesn't assuming that
it doesn't end this is all the past and
maybe he hasn't done any of this for 20
years that doesn't excuse any of it by
any stretch God now but just this what
do you make of just the way that we deal
with these stories it's a very very
difficult thing to talk about so I would
compare it i would use the analogy of
the death penalty i know this is like a
crazy so stay with me or so i'll go with
you i am against the death penalty I
wasn't always against the death penalty
I was raised by Mormon parents in nor
Texas you know it took me a while they
came out as an atheist at 14 but it took
me a while to start to really understand
my views politically my philosophies and
things like that it takes a lifetime to
develop who you are as a human being and
have to come out as against the death
penalty in Texas like that might have to
i don't like a bigger coming up I got
the hell out of there so yeah but yeah
so in Texas your people love the death
penalty I after a lot of careful
consideration I realized that the death
penalty for moral reasons for economic
reasons for many reasons I'm against the
death penalty but probably one of the
most tangible arguments is that it only
takes one person being wrongfully put to
death it only takes one person having
their life taken away by the state by a
jury of peers that made that decision
and then finding later DNA evidence some
sort of you know link that shows oh it
was that other guy it wasn't this guy
yeah he never should have been convicted
in the first place and the truth is
we've seen it happen enough we've seen
it happen where people spend 30 years in
prison until they're finally released
because they found better evidence and
it only takes one and so because of that
I look at something like this Cosby
situation and it's a sad truth I
personally think that he did it I mean
how at this point I do not when you have
30 women who have come out but if the
laws were in place that allowed for
example just one girl to say I don't
like that guy he raped me and no
evidence is required no due diligence is
required and that guy goes to prison or
that guy gets put on a sex offender list
if the laws were were balanced in such a
way that that's all it took that
wouldn't be justice either right and I
don't want to put the burden on the
women i think that's nothing I'm a woman
I'm sitting here thinking like in it's
hard for me to even come out and say
these things because of course I'm gonna
get all sorts of hate for saying that
yeah but justice is really
complicated in he said she said
situations and the real tragedy of this
Cosby stuff is not that this icon has
fought
off of his pedestal it's that it took so
long for women to feel safe enough to
come out that that statute of
limitations has passed right so that's
why the story is so nuts because not
only are they all repeating basically
the same things that happened to them
but then even after that you know that
he was willing I'm going to help you in
your career then there was the interview
on PBS where he thought the camera was
often you could see the way he was sort
of bullying the reporter into not asking
many more questions or not airing a
question that had been asked and that
combined with we've got to remember you
were just saying 1983 you were seven
years old guess what I was doing in 1983
you were probably not even far okay I
say you know so this is an air that I
wasn't even alive in yeah and I know
that gender roles were different I know
that women have made so much headway and
think about like there can be no
victim-blaming in this right think about
the situation the balance of power how
those women must have felt at that time
there is it basically they were
incapable of coming out at the time and
the fact that now we're living in a
world that's the one silver lining is
that we're living in a culture in a
society now where they do feel safer to
be able to come out and where there are
protections under the law we're starting
to get better at understanding sex crime
and an understanding that it's not okay
if a woman says no it's not okay if it
requires that you drugged her it is not
okay so it's sort of though the internet
or the whole media now is sort of a
catch-22 because on one hand the women
in the old days if this happened and
this happened to a woman in 1975 and she
went to her lawyer and then they went to
Cosby's lawyer they could threaten and
shut it down real quick and she would
have almost no recourse now it's like
she can go and write something on
Huffington Post but then at the same
time it starts that mass feeding frenzy
which is one of the reasons that I
haven't talked about it that much
because I'm trying not to add into that
yeah because what it starts is it starts
the ability of a single human being to
provide an understanding or a perception
of legality that is not founded in the
justice system and that's
where it becomes problematic but at the
same time it also is empowering yeah I
mean it's such a complicated issue and I
think that the the big takeaway here is
that complex issues require complex
thinking and this is a nuanced issue and
it's not like I'm Pro Cosby like it's
not i think it's disgusting what he did
yeah but it's also not like I'm pro you
know being able to say something and put
somebody away for life based on based
just on verbal testimony and so there's
a lot of interweaving factors that make
this mostly just a sad situation for
everybody involved yeah all right well I
mean I think that's pretty much sums up
all my feelings what are your feelings I
mean do you think he did it not think he
did it are you trying to back him can
you separate the art from the artist and
then what they do in their private life
and all that stuff let us know in the
comments down below and don't forget to
subscribe